[Music]
it's in leicester on this shabby
industrial estate
that 40 percent of boohoo's clothes are
made
last year many of its suppliers were
mired in allegations of slave labor
it's a world away from boohoo's
glamorous image
selling cheap fashions to its young and
trendy customers
the backdrop to its adverts is america a
lucrative market
that's now under threat u.s law is tough
on imports of goods made with forced
labor
us customs is being urged to ban clothes
from boohoo
and much of its supply chain in
leicester until
proof they are made without exploitation
that was news to factory owner syed
khilji
he said a u.s import ban would hurt but
insisted working conditions
had improved greatly if american
government
taking any action and if they have
enough evidence to do that
then yes that will be a effect but
i'm sure now on there won't be a problem
in leicester
i am 100 confident on that
british lawyer duncan jepson has asked
for two bands
one on boohoo and one on most of its
suppliers
us customs has told him there's enough
evidence
to start an investigation what obviously
we'd all like who those of us who are
interested in the
improving labor conditions is for boohoo
to really get to grips with the
governance of their supply chain
to ensure that there is no wage theft to
ensure that
people have proper contracts
who who has 14 million online customers
last year its profit soared to 92
million pounds
a fifth of its sales were in the united
states
if your business model is that your
supply chains uh making people work for
much less than the minimum wage in
appalling working conditions and you're
undercutting the marketplace
um that's unfair competition and
you're driving legitimate businesses
out of business and that should never be
allowed
in a statement boohoo said the group has
not
been notified of any investigation by
u.s customs and border protection
but we are confident in the actions that
we are taking
to ensure that all of the group's
products meet and exceed the cbp
criteria on preventing the product of
forced labor
entering the u.s or any of our markets
one of the issues that leicester reveals
is that the
the brand uh boohoo in this case
has no legal responsibility for
what happens in its suppliers and i
think that's a concern and i know
a lot of people in the uk think the law
needs to be strengthened so that they
are in some way
more responsible for what happens in
their supply chain
forty percent of boohoo's clothes are
made in leicester's factories
the company says it has already taken
action against
64 suppliers who did not meet its
standards
marty brunt sky news leicester